not a people person tired of dealing
with hotel staff please see the
Velociraptor for checking the hen the
hotel in Japan has 72 rooms but only 10
human staffers there are robot porters a
robot concierge and trued each on a
bedside robot that can answer questions
about the time the weather the room
temperature and even control the lights
facial recognition allows for keyless
entry but sometimes it struggles to put
a face to that room number the human
staffers are there for emergencies and
some of the cleaning the idea is to
improve efficiency and productivity by
reducing labor costs well if the robots
don't malfunction